here now with more the co-host of the
five judge jeanine pirro fox news
contributor joe concha you know why do i
get the sinking feeling um you never
hear judge
uh chuck schumer criticize any
democratic candidates why his mitwell
depends on the quality of candidate how
about he can get off his ass get out of
kentucky and go on the campaign trail
and fight for every candidate and help
them win
you know sean i couldn't agree with you
more you have to wonder why he's taking
a swipe and this is what he's doing at
trump-backed candidates you have to
wonder why is he rolling over why is he
basically giving up you know when he
should be the one who should be out
there and making sure that republicans
are out there voting you know the party
that controls the narrative is the party
that controls the vote
right now mitch mcconnell should be
controlling the narrative with what's
going on in this country that you so
aptly described in your open with this
inflation reduction act which has
nothing to do with inflation reduction
and the fact that what we've got now is
a is a leftist socialist progressive uh
uh
president who is not only raising taxes
and hiring 87 000 new irs agents to sick
it on all the rest of us but what we've
got is we've got taxes going up we've
got inflation we've got all of the
problems that we're dealing with right
now and then we've got people saying you
know what the fact that hunter biden's
laptop story was suppressed it's it was
a good thing we can suppress your first
amendment rights because we don't want
donald trump to be elected these people
are more than socialists they're
communists this is like a third world
country and mitch mcconnell ought to
understand right now that if he doesn't
get up and fight for republicans then he
should just get out of the way
you know joe contra you cover the media
better than anybody i'm by the way i'm
sure you miss humpty dumpty i'm sure
that's that's devastating news for you
um uh because i think you're the best we
haven't seen the last movie
thank you i don't think he's gonna last
in the babylon
is that where he's headed or media
matters one of the others
it won't be any at any network that i
can see but let's get to that it's an
additional
msnbc or media matters one of those two
uh there's something one in the same
right
the echo it's an echo chamber all right
so let me ask about the media's being
complicit in all of this they're the
ones that were perfectly fine with
hillary's dirty russian dossier they
passed it off as being real it was not
real they went out in unison in one
voice echoing the democratic party and
saying hunter biden's laptop was russian
disinformation without even looking into
the issue and so you have to wonder in
every election year you know what will
their messaging be this time because it
will be in sync with the democratic
party that we can expect no
we're already seeing that right sean uh
the inflation reduction act magically
went away as the actual name of the bill
and it's called the democrats uh tax and
health and climate change bill suddenly
inflation's reduction went away because
this thing doesn't reduce inflation and
then you know you just see the cheering
going on right
they embrace uh white house chief of
staff ron claim when he compares joe
biden to jfk and eisenhower as you
mentioned before one difference those
presidents were exceptionally popular
and seen as competent and coherent and
eisenhower his average approval rating
was 65 while in office jack kennedy 70
while in office joe biden reuters poll
just out this is post inflation
reduction act he's at 38 approval 57
percent disapproval so we keep hearing
all this cheering from the president and
his allies in the media uh and there are
many that joe biden has jomentum uh well
just because you passed this massive
spending bill along party lines and lied
to the american public saying it's going
to reduce inflation that doesn't mean
it's a win and and republican candidates
starting with mitch mcconnell at the top
in terms of running the senate and then
saying to the candidates that are all
running in places like arizona and
pennsylvania wisconsin this is your
opportunity to use this in a campaign ad
run against this thing and show the bold
contrast that you're going to do
if you get in office in terms of
reducing inflation or violent crime or
getting back to energy independence but
you don't hear ever democrats talk about
that that much or about securing the us
southern border for that matter and
fentanyl killing young americans because
if they run on issues they lose so it
all goes back to focusing on donald
trump judge it's not complicated if
republicans run on keeping every town
and every city safe and secure and
hiring police and eliminating no bail
and refunding the police if they run on
parental rights and education and get
rid of woke education crt and
and of course the gender identity to
first grade teaching that's been going
on and they stick to reading writing
math science history
and computers i think they'll win on
those issues if they run on securing the
borders that's a winning issue if they
run on energy independence that is a
winning issue uh it doesn't seem that
complicated to me if they really push
that these issues hard they will win
well
they don't even have to push the issues
all they have to do sean is put it in
front of the american people can you
afford food can you afford gas are you
able to buy an electric car do you feel
safe in your town do you have a job has
your business suffered have you lost
your business as a result of being
locked down from coven you know all of
these questions let's talk about
fentanyl let's talk about the border
crisis you don't even have to say
anything other than the reality of
what's going on under the democrats and
shame on mitch mcconnell if he's ready
to roll over right now he ought to move
out of the way because we've got the
narrative we should control the vote
well said judge thank you joe thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else